we gonna hang out with Rick James to
that you know I'm saying and he comes
out the room when I look at him and I'm
not bullshitting Maxine like like an
orange his order or whatever I seen and
started taking it and he was mad nigger
wish man which was right up my alley
I'm one of the baddest of
all time one of the best thing is when
the best-lookin you've
ever seen hold my drink bitch
keep walking see any chick lit the whole
Saturday face man
[Music]
I'm Rick James bitch enjoy yourself
you got closer started hanging out my
brother didn't do anything
so at night when Eddie would break out
we would all be doing it getting crazy
and wild if I was hanging with Rick he
had to sting with me where he used to
always like with me man I don't I
don't know what what started it but you
know he was hanging out with the big
dogs you know you know Charlie didn't
know he was doing crazy things and I had
a straightening mouth sometimes that'll
go upside his head things escalated to
the point where you know my man got too
familiar and I ended up half in the whip
his ass man no because you know he would
step across the line habitually he's a
habitual liar step one first time you
know I had in the whipping his ass we
went to studio 54 we walking up into the
VIP section you know I'm looking around
and see these damn girls they think and
all of a sudden I heard something good
my back
[Applause]
yeah it's ringing remember make this
song he had put out call unity and this
was a distance and this was imprinted in
that black head in his for at least a
week that was the funniest and so
that weird space cuz I'm like yeah this
is Rick James he's a star maybe I'm
overreacting
actually with you like maybe I shouldn't
do nothing but my ghetto sad was going
yo stomp this out right
here
the is wrong with him I'm that
nigga to steal one you know I'm saying
was he gonna smack me back I'm rich and
he's Charlie Murphy I waited cuz I knew
what hotel he was standing and he you
know went home and I said I'll be right
back I shout over to the hotel went up
to his room knocked on the door so then
he comes in there and I said look bitch
I'm Rick James he had his hand pack to
throw another right hand with he's
coming for his camp caught him at the
front tip teller like he gave me some
kind of Bruce Lee cross kick or
something I kicked the out of him
[Applause]
when is knocked out and then he screams
out Sakai at the one in the front
he had crooked eyes and she was one I
was looking at me the other one was
looking at Rick hey Rick head ain't over
by the window now darkness the tables
are turned north and whatever you like
take one more step I'm
kickin this nigga out the
with fries
you know you was off what you did to me
earlier look what you did in my face
I'm sorry telomere it was an accident I
was having too much fun
our fewer troops the stickiest of the
ickey you want to talk with the old boy
Rick games yo man my forehead is bumping
me now that you mention it I think I'm
bleeding inside my chest but I got the
medicine bitch come over here and have
sex with Charlie Murphy I'm Rick James
bitch that was had that particular
incident in you but it wasn't the last
time I had to represent a represent what
possess don't you think I'm a little old
if you tell you karate you probably take
it with the little kids put my ass in
his dreams I told you Charlie has
delusions of grandeur in his hand I'm
tellin what's happening